Boom. All right. With live, what's going on man? What do you got there?
Text messaging people. No, we'll shut your phone off. Yeah,
just put it on silent silence. Mood.
How long have you been in America now for your,
you're only here for like two weeks, right? Uh, yeah,
I came for two week and three days. And the ice,
you invited me on the, uh, the UFC. And did you enjoy it? Yeah.
Was Great.
It was my first time at the u s the first time or even at an MMA even.
You've never been doing MMA and really, no. In France. So boring, you know,
you know that, uh,
now he's pretty beaten friends and you can't hate the guy when he's in on the
floor.
So that's why it used to be boring in France because they fight like striking.
And then when the guy take you down and then he's just busy and just
submissions. Yeah. Oh, that's interesting. So the MMA rules,
when they would go to the ground, no striking at all. Striking.
So that's why he went to the body even in the book. Oh, I think, yeah.
In the buddy that can. Okay. But you can't punch the face. So boring.
That aside, I'd never, I'd never been in there. I mean me even friends,
but UFC at two, four one was crazy. Especially the fight,
the Diaz fight and the, and the,
and the main event was now as a kickboxing champion.
And when you watch MMA, do you,
I know that you've been training and I know that you spent some time while
you're out here at Aka. Yeah.
Are you thinking of eventually make your way to the UFC?
I'm not thinking that's what, that's what I will do. You will do. Yeah.
That's what I will do. That's what I, I want to do, you know, uh,
yeah. As you said, I'm the greeter now. I have five belt.
My, my first dream before groin was to, to become the, yeah.
The greatest kickboxing in the world. Kickboxer in the world.
I wanted to beat the, everybody in my division.
That's what I did before Niki hosken was the champ champ and defeated since six
years. Uh, yeah. W it was the greatest ingredient. And I was like, Damn, how,
how do I'm going to beat him? You know? He's so, he's so strong and I beat him.
I beat him yet twice I beat everybody. So after that,
before people was asking me,
do you think to go to MMA because I think you should do something great in
there. I was like, no, I don't like him at me. I don't want, I don't like,
like Wesleyan bs. I don't like this kind of sport. I'm a striker, you know?
I was like, no, I like it. And yet two years ago I was like, damn,
I think I like it. You know? Cause I, I tried once and uh, I really,
I really like it, you know? What did you like,
do you like MMA training or did you like MMA training, MMA training and Gigi,
so I was, and I was watching Jujitsu all the time on TV and more.
I watched Jujitsu. I was like, Oh, this is so complicated. It's so,
it's not only two guys who are rolling and making string stuff on the
underground, is this more than, than, than that? So I was like, oh,
it's complicated. It's very, it's not easy. So I,
yeah, I wanted to learn that. I wanted, I wanted someone to teach me that.
And uh, yeah, I was thinking about, man, man, now I really want to do it.
I want to do you know what Conor McGregor, uh, couldn't do, you know,
he was the best in MMA in the one Columbus Sport and you wanted to be the
Columbine, um, Floyd, Floyd Mayweather and another combat sport.
He wanted to be the greatest in two combustible different combat sports.
He couldn't do it. He failed. And that's what I want to do it.
And I think I really, really will do it.
I'm the best in kickboxing and I want to be the best in MMA.
And I think I read them.
If kickboxing was as popular as MMA,
do you think you'd still have the same desire?
Do it? Yes. Yes, yes. Because you just want to be the best.
Because I'm young, you know, I'm 26, uh, I,
my dreams came true. You know, I'm the best in kickboxing.
My nickname is the best. I'm really the best. So,
well, I'm a big fan of yours and, uh,
I was really excited to get you in here and one of the things I was really
interested in, uh,
is that you sort of changed your style and you were more movement oriented and
you would win on points, but then you started fucking people up.
You started hitting like people like Nicki Holt's kid had said that about you,
that you're a mover. Yeah. That you're a runner.
I was trying to say it and the Nice, that's what he said. But man,
you changed that around you. You don't want people out
because B a yeah. My first, my first big,
big fight in,
in glory was against sneak cameras and that was only my third fight in glory.
Uh, as I beat the rank number two, who was mutual Gruner,
uh, as I beat him, the, they put me, um,
a title shot right after and I was like, Nicole's can is really,
really complicated. You were like 24, right? Yeah, I was 24. That's very young.
Yeah. Fight Nikki Holtzclaw. Yeah, I was, I was, yeah, I was,
I was impressed by him because he's very good. He's very good. And I still,
I still impressed by him because for me it's very, very great champ. It was,
and um, I was like, I will not knock him out. I used to, before Gloria,
I used to fight every month. Sometime I read to fight.
I used to fight three times a month and, um, I used to be, yeah.
Really? Yeah. Because of tournament,
I used to knock people out at the first round and, uh,
when I saw Nikki I was like, okay, I will not go for the k o.
So I trained myself to do all five rounds to make points and to,
and to stay myself, like funny in the ring and um, yeah.
And make a lot of moon movement, heat jokes, uh,
play with our John Share, you know, and that's what I did. And uh, yeah.
And I kept going that way after Nikki, I kept the same style,
the same side of Samsung. And once I failed, you know, uh,
I lost the fight because, uh, because of that my, my diet wasn't very good,
you know? Uh,
I make a good first round and then I was tired as fuck.
So I couldn't do the job what I wanted to do and then I took a diet.
Now my story, my dad is perfect. And what did you change?
Like what were you eating before? Before I was like, okay,
I f to prepare a fight. I started two months before the fight,
the GD and then, uh, before I was like, okay, still two months,
okay, start more. I stopped next week the Diet,
I start to move to neutral and then we are two weeks before the fight. I'm like,
damn, six skills to lose. Okay.
I started today and then I come in a five week and I never started the Diet and
I started like in the,
and like three days before the fight I had five kilo to lose six kilo to lose
three days. And I was like, okay, I don't eat anything no more.
Now I just train, train sonar training with no food, with no food,
even no water. And that's was, that's, that wasn't smart. You know,
it's so hard for people to believe that world champions do things like that.
Yeah. But that is the case sometimes.
And sometimes you need a bad fight to sort of snap you out of it and realize,
hey, I have to be disciplined for many, many months out and invest. Right.
You know what the first thing growers say to my manager before when I won the
first title, they say, Hey, Cedric is very lucky because we don't,
we don't even know how, how does he come? He arrive at,
at this level with no, no diet, no, you know,
no strategies, no trainer, nothing. There was,
there was very surprised and yeah, I, I think,
I think a lot about this and that's why now I'm very professional and after that
diet, I start to knock everybody out. So what did you change in your diet?
Like what do you eat now? Now it's like, you know, my diet and Francis,
she's very famous, you know her name is Cecile golden coach. She's a,
the name is golden coach. Golden cause that's a real name
and yeah.
And she take care of many champions in France and the, yeah, she,
I cannot tell you exactly what,
what is in inside my diet because it's so complicated.
But I told her I don't want,
I don't want you to tell me how many grams and this and this and this.
Just tell me right. What I need to eat Monday,
Tuesday morning, evening. And that's what, that's what she did.
She just follow her instructions, follow instruction.
I live a meal prep company. Someone who makes the meals for you.
Do it all yourself? Not yet. Yeah. Yeah. There was some in France,
in Paris especially, but I didn't choose yet.
So what kinds of foods are you eating? I love African food, but Africa,
African food is really,
really not good for my diet is because a lot of oil,
a lot of meat. Uh, sound good. That sounds great. That sounds great.
But wait, no, I used to eat, um,
Japanese food. Japanese. I really like Japanese food,
Sushi fish as Derek food is very healthy.
So I like Japanese food, Korean food.
So that's what I used to eat when I'm, I go out restaurant.
So now what does she have you eating now? Now I don't have to prepare any fight.
I just keep on shape. So I eat what I want now. Which one?
What I want today. Today? Yes.
But starting September and then they're going to start a new diet and yeah,
mornings like two eggs, two eggs. And um, how much do you have to lose?
Like what is your normal weight?
My normal weight in kilograms is I'm 85 85.
What does that like find seven day? What is that? How many?
85 kilograms to pounds.
Maybe one night when 90 yeah, it's on one 60.
1.2 0.21 88 and you have to get down to one 71 17.
Yeah. So when I, when I say, when I say that in, uh,
in naked there was like, oh, you good? Oh yeah. MMA fighters lose a lot.
A lot. A lot. But before it was before, oh,
the biggest thing I did is in seven weeks I lost a 15.
No, 17, 17 kilos. Oh Wow. Seven weeks. Yeah. Last time I came to AK,
I was 95 95 eas is 200 202 plots.
Yeah. 95 kills. We gotta calculate here. What is it? Two 10.
So you are 210 pounds. Yeah.
And seven week later I lost the 15,
17 kilograms because of the sin. Ah, yeah. Yeah.
That was very, very hard. But your energy levels. Okay. What are you doing?
All that? Everything was good. I was just training twice a day and diet,
diet everyday, every other day. Yeah. Now kickboxing is huge in Europe. I mean,
very big people were big
people. I mean, I had, um, Rico Verhoeven on when we discussed this,
like how enormous kickboxing is in Holland and in Europe and in America.
For whatever reason, it never caught on. I don't understand it.
I've been a fan of glory and I've been trying to tell people about them for a
long time.
Uh, I cannot blame USA for that because the,
the legalize MMA, so MMA just more,
more attractive for people, you know, then people who doesn't know shit about,
about fighting, they just watch MMA is like,
oh two people are fighting then that's interesting. You know,
kickboxing and like things like sport, like way Thai kickboxing.
If he doesn't know the rules, it's kind of, yeah, you just want and you don't,
you don't understand, you don't understand. But MMA is more easy to understand,
you know, just, yeah. It's just a fight between two people. So I don't,
I really don't know why kickboxing is not a, it's not yet.
Maybe at the same level as MMA in USA. What,
what's crazy to me is boxing is very respected in the United States and MMA is
very respected.
But one of the things that people like about MMA is stand up there.
Like the striking. Yeah. But the best striking,
it's like glory or more tie.
Like the best elite kickboxers are the best strikers. That's right.
But I think people love the cage. People love the blood.
So small gloves.
That's why that's all people like people don't like you too.
Don't like how you say them.
A knockdown like k o or nothing. Yeah.
They don't like to brag. And the one, two, three, no. They like, yeah,
they like to see two to watch k. Oh,
so that's what I think that's what they prefer. Yeah. And then they, well,
is there a movement at all to try to get MMA full MMA legalized in France?
Uh, I think in January it's going to be, it's going to be okay.
So they're going to have to allow strikes on the ground. Yeah. Everything,
every soon. Sooner in January. So in January, January. Oh,
okay. And I think UFC going to come in,
so they'll probably be USC and Paris for sure. And think so. That sounds wild.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well the more guys like you get involved in MMA though,
the more complicated kickboxing though, because like when elite fighters,
world champions, like yourself make a jump to MMA,
then people might look at kickboxing as a stepping stone instead of as a valid
individual sport. Yeah, yeah, that's right. But,
uh, you mean when the guy has stepped from kickboxing to MMA? Yeah.
They're like,
maybe people won't care as much about kickboxing because they're looking at it
as a stepping stone to MMA. Yeah, of course. And the, yeah. Yeah, that's right.
That's what I, that's what I wanted. I want to do or so because I think, um,
for a guy from a kickboxing to to go in MMA,
it's not really difficult for him if, uh, yeah, if you learn the,
the crown game and wrestling, take rest and take them defense.
If you learn that it's going to be, yeah.
More simple than the guy who come from way tie, you know, more ties.
It's really different. Like kickboxing, kickboxing.
When you fighting kickboxing,
you move the lot already in understand standing target instead of we,
I wait, I you did. If you watch [inaudible] you fight. They don't move a lot,
you know, they stay still and the fight is,
is all about poets for kicks, for punches.
So why do you think that's different? Because the clench because of elbows,
knees like, because of the, the, the movement, the movement in MMA,
they stay still and in Quebec seen the, there is no, you know,
there was no break. You know, they just keep fighting. One, two, three, one,
two, three, one, two, three. And the in Weta is more like one, one,
one elbow, knees, and yeah. Also by the cleaning.
Just good for everyone because then, you know, in May, yeah. The Red Tie club.
Yeah. Of course. This is good for me. Now in France,
is it easy to get wrestling? Do you get wrestling training?
I uh, in France I get grappling training.
I think here in USA you call it busy No-gi you, yeah,
yeah. That's what I, that's why I'm training in France.
Take downs or take down defense wrestling. But you know, this,
this type of, um, of, uh,
No-gi training I get is a little bit different,
like as visually because we start, uh,
on our feet and, uh,
and we used to west and then after the take down, we continue,
right? So it's not like an Olympic western ride, but it's,
they call that [inaudible] you have snow looted labor is what they're called
Brazil. But I I know what you're saying. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
so in America, most presenters you to, they start on the ground already,
they'll start on the knees or something like that to avoid accidents because you
know,
you got a class four 40 people rolling around together and they're trying to
tackle each other and people blow their knees out and things on those lines.
Yeah. That's why I'm training in that in, in Paris, very big team.
The coaches major admin is very good. And the,
he say for the first few times, very, very good. I learned fast for,
I learned very fast. Of course you're an elite athlete now at 26,
but how much time do you think you need between now and when you have your first
MMA fight? You know, what is my dream? Yes.
Now is now I beat everybody.
So like I'm getting birds in the, in kickboxing, you know,
I still defending right,
my title because I like it because of the cash price also. And,
uh, my dream is
I still didn't contract in the, for one, one year in health,
little bit more than one year.
My dream is prepare myself to MMA during one year.
So I still got time and after the, at the end of the contract,
directly go to UFC and take the chimp for the,
a direct dieters shot all at the five run guy.
I really, I really, really would like to fight new ideas or,
uh, Anthony Petty's for my first fight,
MMA to y to, to, to shook,
only to show the world, to,
to show everybody that a guy who come from kickboxing directly.
His first fight is gangs, thug guy in MMA and he,
he fucked him up. So that's what I want to do and I really,
really believe in me and I know I will. I can and I will do it.
Now have you been in talks with UFC?
Does UFC know about your plan? Not yet. Not yet. What they do now. Uh,
but I think after the show they have already, so now they're going to know.
So your training at Aki was at the first time you ever trained up there?
It was my second time. Second time. When did you train before?
Before it was one years ago. November. Yeah.
I came here after my glorified, uh, I broke my ribs,
so I took a little bit, uh, vacation in Thailand and then, uh, after that,
yeah, I just fly to, uh, Aka San Jose and yeah, I meet,
I met everybody. DC Cubby wasn't there,
but I met a lot of great, great teammates. Uh,
the western level is just amazing. The,
so I met have also Javier Mendez. Yeah, I see.
So that's a great camp for a guy like youtube because it's very wrestling heavy.
Yeah. Yeah, that's, that's what I, that's what I like. I want to turn, you know,
what did I say to me? Gee, in front, I say, I want to train western busy.
Like I want to be a world world champion of wrestling, you know,
so I just want to think wrestling like a restaurant.
I don't just want to train my take down defense or shit like that. No, I just,
I want people to be afraid of me in an underground, you know,
I'll say learn fast as I really like it.
I think that's the level I want to get.
And how's it going when you train at Aka, are you hanging in there? Like,
do you find it uncomfortable? Like of course as a,
as a striker, uh, inch writing. Yeah. Um,
my level is higher than anybody else in Aka but in the ground.
Yeah. And fucking focused on, so yeah.
Everybody did. The, I taught everybody every day. I taught in the guys. Yeah.
Yeah. For the movement. And uh, yeah,
they say I learned you I have plans on tapping. Yeah, of course. Yes.
For the moment I type and uh, because I'm learning and they say I learned very,
very fast. Like they show me once and then I get it, you know,
five minutes later I get it. And so I feel confident for the future
in [inaudible] and I think I would do it. You well,
I'm hoping you do.
It's always exciting to see world champions and particularly kickboxing,
make that way to MMA, to the UFC. And for a guy like you,
it's the perfect thing because you're so young,
cause you're 26 and you're already a very accomplished world champion.
That's right. And I think I'm thinking about, um, Israel,
Addison, you know, he, he, he needed and he couldn't do it,
you know, but he was very smart. Israel, the way he planned it,
he really worked on his take down defense and made sure that he,
by the time he made it to the UFC, he was already at an elite level.
It wasn't a lit, but he got a tighter shot in the,
in glory and he lost. And after that he went to UFC, you know,
so, uh, that's what I want to do. I want to be the only one to,
to, to be able to yeah. To, to do that, you know,
and the glory. Kickboxing chimp and then UFC champ,
he fought wellness right when this, yeah, very close fight. Just,
it was very close. I thought he won. Some people thought it was and some, no.
Yeah. But Jason Wellness's elite is the lead of course. Yeah. Very,
very high level fighter. Yeah. Well, Gloria is like soc side. I'm such a fan.
I love watching it, man. It's like one of my favorite things to watch.
It drives me crazy that it's not popular and I was very excited when it was on
spike TV in America. It was, they were making a big deal out of it.
It looked like they were gonna, you know, try to promote it as much as possible.
And they tried it for a little while, then they stopped and now it's on ESPN,
a little bed. It's on UFC fight pass, which is great.
I think that the country will grow is very, very multiple places in Holland.
I think French is so support bureau, you know,
some people recognize me and in the street when the,
when were way out in front yet because of glory is very popular in Europe.
Well, La Martel growing heart. He's, is he the guy that you're fighting next?
Eh, he's the guy who want me to beat his ass next.
I don't know if I would fight him. Nick, do you have a fight scheduled next? No,
not yet. Growing, Heart's been talking a lot of shifts. Yeah.
Fucking little shit. You know,
I'm the money fight [inaudible] against me, but the, yeah,
I would like to fight Milton next because, uh,
when we fight it shows other people really, really like it. It's a great fight.
Yes. Very good. It was very fighter. It's very entertaining. And the, yeah,
people like it. So, but you've already beaten them.
Sorry if you already beaten him. Yeah, of course. Yes. You've of course.
What did, how did that fight go? I'm trying to remember. Uh,
I won like point, but it wasn't the good fight for me, you know,
it wasn't a good, when I look at that fight today. Yeah, for sure.
I'm seeing that, that four years ago. How many years ago was this?
Four years ago? Yeah. Yeah. Four years ago. Yeah. Before the bell. Yeah.
Four or five years ago I was in firees and the, yeah,
when the fight and uh, yeah,
for me it's going to be interesting if I fight him because I fought everybody in
that division, so I don't know who they going to be.
Oh going to be my next opening. But yeah, sounds good for for Milton.
And then, yeah, he's going to be, he's going to be on the rematch, you know,
on the rematch. We metro match for them.
So from then out, one year plus,
then you make your way into the world of the UFC. No matter what,
even if glory comes with more money of glory is like, listen, Doom Bay,
we love you. [inaudible] I really, I really like glory,
you know. Uh, Gloria is my, my first great experience as a, yeah.
As a real champ. And, uh, the, they're doing a great job for me,
you know, uh, I really like glory, but
I have to think about me for, and a legacy. Yeah. My legacy. And,
uh, I, I like to do what I love to do. So for my, my,
I love kickboxing, I love defending my title. I love the, the, the,
um, the glory. Um, even, you know, the, the team I love every,
every, everybody and everything in glory. But tomorrow, I don't know.
I don't know. I just going to follow my, my goal, follow my, um,
my needs and uh, yeah, I want to be the,
the, I hope the first French UFC champion.
And uh, that's what I, that's what I want. I want to check the wall. I want to,
I want to write, uh,
my story and a new story people never had about it.
So even if Gloria [inaudible]
[inaudible] is a big, big, big money, you know,
I just want to follow what I want. You just have a plan.
You have a plan and I know I would get more, more after that.
So I mean the thing, I'm confident. So you've been out here now, uh,
you went to the UFC events and then you did some training at Aka, like, uh,
w when you are outside of camp, say like, whenever your fight is scheduled,
how much, uh, what kind of training you doing when you're not in camp?
Are you mixing it up now and trying to do a lot of Jujitsu? A lot of BJJ.
1:00 AM nothing. Kim.
So my, um, my conditioning trainer, Valentino Gargiulo,
he followed me everywhere. He's with me today. And, uh,
we just train strange conditioning because before that was my weakness,
the condition I used, I used to knock everybody out at the first round.
So I never trained my condition.
I never took it very serious because I used to knock people out at the first
round. So when I did my first five rounds,
I was like, wow, damn, the conditioning is so, so important.
So that's why I'm training a lot. You know,
a strange for sure conditioning and also, yeah, when I'm not,
when I don't have a fight, kickboxing, fight plan, I trained BCG,
I trained wrestling, MMA and aga is a completely different conditions.
It's crazy when you, when you Wester with a guy and then you, you,
you get up and you're trying to strike, you're exhausted. Yeah.
Arms are filled with blood. [inaudible] nothing. Yeah, it's very crazy.
Now what kind of strength and conditioning are you doing and how often are you
doing it? Like say if you are, if you're preparing for a fight,
how many days a week do you do strength and conditioning?
When I am preparing for a fight, uh, everyday. Everyday.
Everyday it's not, of course it's not the same training,
but every day I see Valentino and uh, we train together. Yeah.
Everyday I train more conditioning and strange more than kickboxing.
Really. I don't have a trainer in kickboxing,
but that's right. Yeah. Really people,
people don't believe it doesn't believe it when I say that,
but [inaudible] yourself. I turned myself. That's insane. I have of course,
my friend in the, in France who old hold meats for me for sure.
I can meet for my myself.
He old miss for me and we just taught together.
We just plan a game plan together for a fight. We just don't,
I'm my own coach, you know, that is crazy.
I never had a coach at your level to be your own. You've never had a coach.
Of course. I had a first teacher.
He told me after that he couldn't teach me anymore because because of his job,
you know, when I,
when I was young and then I just move from a to country and countries and
countries to learn to learn, to learn. And then came back in France, Paris,
and it just turned myself. That is insane.
How many world champions just trained themselves? I think nobody.
How do you do that? That sounds crazy. But why didn't you get another coach?
I don't know. Because I didn't find a coach who can, I don't know.
I can just teach me. I really don't know. That's a good question. I don't,
I don't, why did I, what? I didn't found a new coach.
I don't know.
Cause you're not thought about making any trips to Holland or the Thailand or
you know, Bodo in France. Sure. So I was raised there.
That's where I started the kickboxing. I started with full contact, you know,
full contact shore. Rick roofers was my first. I hadn't really, yeah,
why I was watching Rick roof roof.
His bread is one of the big coaches in Mia. He's name is them.
His brother took to Griffiths. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's a friend of mine.
He's great. Oh Nice. Yeah. He's a out of Milwaukee. Yes. Yeah. Roofing sport.
Yeah. Yeah. So when I start that for contact, I was watching all the fight of a,
of is the jet special? Yeah. Rick Rufus Against Rube Cameron. Ah,
yeah. The first and the second was crazy, crazy,
crazy recruits against [inaudible] for contact fight.
So after, after my, my first coach, uh,
couldn't teach me anymore,
I just float to 'em and sell them because, uh, yeah,
because of Cameron, you know, in my mind I was thinking about, OK, uh,
raise the best kickbox in the planet. Um, um, Harlan. So I went to Holland.
Materialism was famous because of rob Carmen because of, uh,
Ramia Goujon ski shore. And, uh, I went to majority,
my trend them maybe two years, you know,
I was flying a Bordeaux Amsterdam doing two years and,
uh, yeah, uh, the coach was under him or not. He teach me a lot, you know, uh,
I learned a lot there and when I,
I figured out that I couldn't learn anymore, uh, else in maturity,
I just went to Belgium because I met semi-commercial. B is a very,
very great coach for me is the best coach. I never, I never had,
why wouldn't you spend your camps with him then? Why? Yeah, because,
because we meet each other at an event in France and then I saw one of his
fighter, he was fighting and then when I saw his technique,
he's a, his condition. He was, you know,
his first round was looking the same at his fifth round. It was crazy.
A very, very high level condition. His name is Mohammed Endo was very crazy.
And I say that's, that's like this, I want to fight. It was so technical,
you know, and I say that's what like this, I want to fight.
I went to Belgium in Brussels and I trained with him also two years.
I was a driving Paris present Paris [inaudible] two years during two years I
trained with him and I that's with here that um,
I want my first belt against Nick Ellis and he,
if you watch my fights before nickel skin and that fight against the Kilcullen,
he's competed two different fighter.
So why don't you do your camps with him now?
Now because he live in process and I learned, but
I can't anymore. So that's why I left. I mean, but some,
he still in my corner when I fight, I just come, you know,
but I don't train any moments to me. So there's no one in Paris?
No, nor in Bordeaux that you can for me the best, the best, the best, uh,
Tryna the best school is in percentage,
the Queensbury gym and I never found another under the chin with that kind of
fluid. So I cannot train with any coach, you know,
and I just turned myself, my, my friend holds meets for me.
I trained with Valentino.
The conditioning training for me was more important than,
than the kickboxing. Everybody know to keep up. Now we know how to kickbox,
but the difference we will be make with the condition. For me,
it's interesting, you know, there's a thought,
there's a thought process that follows those lines in MMA and it's a Marvin
Marinovich and this guy nick curse on, and they've only trained a few fighters,
but they've had very high levels of success because of their conditioning.
And what they say is that you already know how to fight.
So just let's concentrate on the conditioning and gets your conditioning to a
super high level. And that when you're fighting, you can just go,
yeah, that's right. That's what I say. Everything. When I, when I am,
I give advices to, to people, they say, what should I train these, this,
this technique? I said, listen, between two,
two fighters in the same level, the same experience.
What's gonna make the difference? The condition in the fight. You know,
if you fight one, two, three rounds and then you fucked up, yeah,
they lose the fight. Right. If fight five rounds,
and even if you not good enough, uh,
technically you're gonna win the fight for sure, because you don't get tired.
Yeah, that's fine. Now,
another crazy thing about you that people might not know.
It's like you're a comedian. Yeah, that's right. You're a stand up comedian,
which is hilarious before, but you,
for you to be a world champion kickboxer and a stand up comedian,
that is a very unusual combination. That's right. Because first,
my first dream and Dustin still,
my dream today is to become an actor, comedian.
And the before, before I started a combat sport. Yeah.
I was doing standup. I was, uh, I was in high school also.
I was learning, um, uh, committees and stuff, uh,
actor acting and I really, I really like it.
And then the come the compass boat and then I started to improve myself to
become, yeah, more to fight, to fight the fight. And then I,
I studied a bit, uh, yeah. Stand up acting.
But three months ago I was a, I played in a small movie.
Short movie in France. Yeah. I played that. He's gonna,
he's gonna go out in the shoe and shoe few weeks.
Now when you do stand up in Paris, are you working at comedy clubs?
Like do they have comedy clubs in Paris? It's not in Paris.
A community club in the environment. In Bordeaux, yeah. I was very young. I was,
I used to be young, but I was, yeah, 18, 19.
And so Bordeaux has comedy clubs. Yes.
Coming to club and it's all obviously in French. In France. Of course. Yeah.
Not in English. Have you ever done comedy in English and never. Never. Oh yes.
One in the, I think you can find it in a neutral is uh,
I was um, I was teaching people how to cook out to go,
I have to cook a great the chicken. Yeah, I did it.
I did that with glory. I was promoting my, my, my,
my second fight against Nicola skin and I was trending in Belgium presales and I
did a, I did it [inaudible] one find it on youtube.
So is that something that you would think of doing once you retire from
fighting? Yeah, that's, I really want to do it. That's my first, my first, um,
my first way. That's what I really,
really want to do in from the top of my bottom of UN in the top of my heart
does, that's what I want to become because I read that you,
if you had to choose between being a famous comedian or a famous fighter,
you would choose to be a famous comedian. Yeah. For Shelley. Yeah. Really.
But that's so crazy when you see how good you are fighting yet. You know,
people, people doesn't believe me when I say that, but if,
if I didn't find the, uh,
if kickboxing didn't found me because I think I didn't find,
I didn't found kickboxing, kickboxing, finding me if he works in the, uh,
never find me, I will follow my, my way in a, in comedy stuff. Yeah,
yeah, for sure. And so now I'm good and keep working, so I just follow myself.
Well, you better than good. Now how did you become,
how did check boxing find you? You said found you? Because I was,
I was 16, so 10 years ago I was 16. And, uh,
I was playing soccer, I was playing soccer and uh, I wasn't that good.
I was, yeah, just, I was just fast, you know,
five and in front of the girl I was falling. No, I wasn't that good, you know?
And um, one,
one day my cousin just just call me and say, hey,
in front of the house, in the neighborhood, there is a gym, uh,
boxing is there. Eh, I thought, I thought, I thought that was boxing.
Like Muhammad Ali and Mike Tyson. I said, yeah, if yes, but so what?
He said, yeah, let's go try it. Yeah, it's going to be,
maybe it's going to be funny. You know, I saw,
I saw people goes out from there. The, the how, the how you,
how you call black guy. He says it should be funny. I said, okay,
once we are going to do we going to go there. So after my, uh,
my soccer training, I went there once I tried and I,
I discovered that it was full contact with legs with high kick.
Middle Cake was a little bit strange, but I just follow,
I just trained getting better and better and just, I like it.
So immediately like you caught the guy immediately after my first training,
I went there and you know that, that I, you know,
that my mother was against that. Uh, she said, no, no, no,
I don't want you to, to, to fight. I don't want you to train a boxing.
I don't want any boxing in this house. I was, I cry when the, when she,
she say that because I really like a full contact number spot.
So I cry when I,
when she told me that and I was training but she doesn't, she,
she doesn't know that. She doesn't know the secret. Yeah. Secret was secret.
How old were you when you had your first fight? My first 17. 17 didn't know.
She didn't know. No. So this was for contact or contact,
which may be three years full contact. And then I kicked my peak.
Let's explain it. People don't know. Full contact is a no leg kicks. Yeah.
No. FullContact is no low kicks. Low kicks. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Okay. Kick the legs. Yeah. Lonely. Immediate kinks. Yeah.
You guys have different terms. It's called low kick and yeah,
we call it leg kick. Leg Kicks. Yeah. But low kicks is crazy low. Kicks it.
Correct. So, uh, you just can't kick the likes,
which is interesting cause that's very effective and you're very good at that.
Yeah. It's a big part of your game right now. So,
but I'm better in boxing because I started with this full contact and it's a
little bit, it's a little bit similar than, than boxing. The way you move,
the way you fight because no low kick, no leg kicks. Right. So yeah,
he's a little bit stiff. When I was boxing and when I was training for contact,
I was watching a lot of Muhammad Ali. So yeah,
little movements. Yeah, I'm better in the, in the,
in boxing when I fight kickbox when did your mom find out?
After, after one year after my first fight.
She was like, well, when, what was your, I say, no,
it was a in the soccer training and she said, why do you have gloves and say,
oh, sometime I go to watch boxing and she say,
I told you I don't want you to watch and to to, to fight. I said, no, I do.
I'm don't. I know I'm not training, just watching. She said, no,
I don't want it. And every day I just went to the train to train,
to train and the, she doesn't see me with any,
a black guy or things like that. So one day she was very,
very tired and I say, yeah, uh, mom, listen.
I went to the boxing training and she was like, okay.
And then the day after I wanted the boxing training. So I was like, okay.
I think because she didn't see me with any black eyes. That's,
that's why she was scared first. Yeah. And then she,
she just accept the, the thing because I make 'em infringed.
Recall that fussing, I just, I just went to the training like, fuck it.
I like it. So he do it. And today, what do say in France? Forcing, forcing,
yeah. Forcing. Like we just, uh, we just go, Eh, you don't care.
You don't care if someone, they say don't do that. It's like, fuck yeah,
like four kids. And uh, let me show you a video of my mom.
So it's very funny because sometimes I send her this video, I say, look at you,
look at you. You, you didn't want me to,
to fight for us and now look at you now. She's very excited. Yeah. Well,
I mean she must be happy that you do that now. Now that you're a world champion.
Yeah. She's really to watch you on television. That's my motivation. My mom, oh,
that's beautiful for me is everything. If I come control my stories is,
is amazing. My mom did everything for my sister and me.
[inaudible] look at your mom.
Oh, that's amazing. Yeah.
Wow. That's cool.
Incredible man. Um, man,
that's amazing. That's amazing. And though she's like that,
that's gotta be so crazy. Imagine if you're a mother, you give birth to a boy,
you give birth to a child and then you grow that.
They raise that child and then you watch that child become a world champion.
I must be crazy. Crazy.
It'd be maybe four people up
and she's like, and when I, when I, sometimes when I talk, cause my mother,
I said, listen, I really, I do my best in the gym.
I train every day other than how to, to,
um, uh, to, to knock people out.
And I really hope that I will never get knock out cause I don't want you to see
to see me. Yeah. Fall down. You know, I don't, I don't want her to feel this,
this kind of ambition or I just want her to be, to be happy that I won.
So he trained very hard. So yeah, there it is. We'll watch the video here. Yeah.
That is an amazing video. And you know the,
the woman she's hugging, she doesn't even know her.
It's crazy. Your last fight against the, how do you say his name? Nabi.
Have I live Nivea. Yeah, he's a bad motherfucker, man. He's very good.
And for you to knock him out like that, the way you, nobody knock him out,
you know, it's very tricky. Yeah. He's tricky. Sneaky. Yeah.
That guy fights very technical. Yeah.
But I was so focused on that fight because, did you ever see Robin Bruh?
You know who Robin black as? No. Robin black is a friend of mine and he,
he breaks down fights.
He talks about like what someone did that works so well.
The guy who say enjoyed the acidity. My friends. Yes, yes, yes.
That's exactly right. So immediately he's famous for saying bink, bink.
I know the guy. Yeah. I love that guy. He's a good friend of mine. But uh,
he did a breakdown of your fight,
the way you set up that right hand on the way knocked him out. It's very cool.
It's very cool to see that getting more and more attention not be have is very
good man. So for you to set him up like that to him, second room, I say,
I say before the fire, I said I wouldn't look him up.
I had to stick around cause the second room, the first for me is just warming
up. And then the second one I feel very good.
But it's the most dangerous for a run when you fight against me because the
second one I'm wrong. You know, I just [inaudible] just ready. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm ready for everything. So is, he's a very good fighter.
You set a trap for him though. A trap. Yeah. The way you set that right hand up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. For me. I just follow my, you know, my,
my plan, you know, I just want to fight. I,
I didn't want him to read my Im my move, my movements. Yeah.
So he just,
the Kale came before that knees before that new,
because I touch him with the left hook and the right hook.
It was wobbly on his, on his legs. And then uh, yeah,
he just throw a knee and boom. Yeah. So the finish, that was very impressive.
Very impressive to knock that guy out. And that's has to be,
so as you're looking at your career now,
and you're saying that there's no one else to beat after you knock out a guy,
like not be out, does that make it harder for you to get motivated? No,
because for me it's more when fights more than I'm getting to the top of the
world, like UFC champ and afterwards,
maybe after the UFC belt I will have another, I don't know, maybe a
chance. Western, I don't know. I slipped. That's hilarious. That's crazy. No,
for me, I still get, because if I, now I'm to champs,
so if I lose my, my, my title defense now I would go, I will go down.
So I need to keep the same, same level yet at the same level.
So that's what motivated, motivated me. Yeah.
So when you were telling me that you do a strength and conditioning every day,
like what kind of stuff are you doing today?
Like we talk today and you said that you were running on the beach. Yeah.
So today I wanted to train first like, um, it's not an, it's not strange,
but is, uh, like, um,
I don't know how to call that in English, but uh,
it's like conditioning, uh,
conditioning training we want to do. And I think that's what we will do after.
And conditioning with them as the bike
clothes are amazing. Also, I'm also running, I saw your, your,
your different stuff also running and he's like, he's treating me,
um, the same way I have to, I have to fill the same thing.
I feel inside the cage, inside the ring. So that, that's,
that's the conditioning, uh, training. So today was a relaxed run,
relaxed running. And yet tonight is going to be harder, you know,
where are you training tonight? Tonight?
I think I will train right after the show. Uh, in your gym. All right. Yeah.
And I gotta take a picture. That's my gym.
So I think I chained there because you have there, your gym is so, so fully,
so complete, so exhaustive. So cool. I like it. So you'll see.
How are we going to train? I cannot talk about a, you know,
I'm like, you're the team. Yeah, you're the coach. Tell me what I do pushups.
Okay. I just do it. You just do it. Sometime I ask a question like, uh,
when I'm in the K in the ring, why do I need to do that?
And then he explained to me and then I, okay, let's go. But, uh, no,
I can talk about, uh, exactly the, the, the, the training, what does that mean?
So he has, you do a lot of cardio exercises, but I just want him to,
yeah, that's what I say. Before we started training camp, I say, Hey,
I want my [inaudible] better than never and I want,
I keep my poor even improved my power. He say, I catch you and then we go.
So is there a lot of weightlifting as well? No. No. Not a lot.
We need to maybe twice a week we do that.
Very poor training twice a week. Legs and upper body.
And then what kind of weightlifting are you talking about?
Like Olympic style tree, like kettlebells, how you,
how you conduct and squat,
squats and deadlifts, deadlift, yens presses,
stuff like that. Not Presses, but, uh, we do it any lateral,
like one legs. One leg. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. That's what it is already doing. Yeah.
So I like Rosarito. So you use kettlebells?
I hate kettlebells. Behave. Yeah, that hurt me. Yeah.
I don't like the feeling and I have big hands, so my,
both of my hands inside the Kettlebells, I feel like, oh,
for swings and swings. Yeah. Well as you say, if you learn how to do correctly,
it doesn't hurt as much. Yeah. You just gotta learn how to swing it through.
When I put it through. When he comes here. That's hurt me a lot. Yeah.
Yeah. We got to learn how to just rotate it through. Maybe as you do it,
you rotate it through. Maybe I don't have the technique to calculate it is,
did you ever get a good kettlebell instructor to show you the Kettlebell answer
to? Yeah. I even don't know that. I haven't done their thing.
I could show you a little bit, I'm not qualified to really show you,
but a really good kettlebell instructor. It's a technique as you're swinging,
like if you're like cleans clean as you're doing it,
you're just sort of punching through. A lot of people.
They lift it up and it just, Oh yeah. You don't want that.
You want to control the Kettlebell I got. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll show you some stuff. I, I'm a Kettlebell Fan.
I love them. Yeah, but obviously you see all, all the machines.
I swear I saw the season like at the band. She's all the monkey.
Oh yeah. Yeah. We have a big foot. I have an alien.
I have gorillas. I have a chimp tacos. Yeah.
Just see the big foot one. That's the biggest one. That's fucking huge.
Big Floats. One's like, yeah, that's, I don't know how many kilograms that is.
I still, it's like, yeah we got star wars ones. Yeah, we got a Darth Vader.
Yeah, that was, those are all from on it.
We have a bunch of cool looking kettlebells,
but just regular kettlebells are fine. Yeah, I'm a fan. I just think they're,
the great thing about kettlebells is they make you use your whole body,
make use everything all at once. Not like him.
No regular weight right now. Like isolation exercises. Yes.
Do you do battle ropes? Do you do that? [inaudible] yeah,
I like it the most that I like is the, you know the,
the things where you run, but he's done the electric. She just running. Yes.
We have one of those [inaudible] that's from the same assault bike company.
You said it's called the air runner. Assault air runner. Yeah.
That thing is the shit
on 13% harder than regular running. Oh yeah. I felt, yeah, cause you're,
you're forcing your footsteps. That's what I said.
The volunteer because he wrote me a program like 400 Mitha should do this for a
hundred minutes at 800. I was like, he's fucking difficult than decent machine.
It was like maybe it was [inaudible] it was good. God love her. She is hard.
Yeah. Very good. What about the versa climber? You ever used that one of visit?
That's the one like Oh yeah, I use it once. Oh that's hard.
I got that out there. Yeah. Yeah. For homes. Yeah. No that's amazing.
What a code. You as good or so. Yeah.
It's amazing how many different machines there are.
You could get your cardio on.
So the beautiful thing about it is I like it cause it's variety. Yeah. You know,
different things all the time. Force your body adapt to different things.
My best training, what I like to do is uh, to run,
but on stage and stairs, yes. That's the training I prefer. Yeah.
I do too. Once a week. Yeah. Once a week. Every Thursday morning.
That's the training I prefer because I have big legs and yeah. I uh,
it's also not pounding too right. Cause you're pushing off. Yeah.
You pushing slam. Then it's like when people,
I have friends that run on concrete, I'm like, oof. Yeah.
That fear bad for your knees. I can't be good. He's good for me. I like it.
The hills heel stairs. Yeah. I prefer, yeah, no.
Do you rock? You said you ran on the beach today. Do you have any,
his board Bordeaux doesn't have beaches. Right. Nuts. Nothing.
[inaudible] the biggest to our fall from too far into it to fall. Yeah.
It's too fun to put trainings. That's a great way to run too though,
if you can run on sand. Yeah. And Sandy is very, it's very good for the code.
You and those four legs, you know, that's works out of missiles. Uh,
very deep. Even muscles. Yes. Yes.
Like now when you're training, are you doing strength and conditioning?
Are you using a heart rate monitor? Are you using, what's the brand of
Polo? Polo. Yeah, that's what I use. Yeah. Shortly. He was very famous and the,
it's especially for the trainer because I don't care, you know,
he just look and make his concur is a mathematics.
So he keeps you at a certain heart rate. They want to keep me on that. Do you
monitor your heart rate in terms of like when you wake up to make sure that
you're not overtrained? No, I never do that. No. No. Just I just go to training.
If I feel good, I go train. If I freestyle,
I got trained as a funny man.
Some so many elite fighters the same way I had Terrance Crawford here the other
day. Same thing. Yeah. Just go the train. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I like whole school, old school things. I like also new school things like,
you know, Polo things, you know, I like those kind of new things.
But for me, the, yeah, the, the combat sport is,
it's a mind thing or so, you know, she don't get too much. Um,
how you say that too much. I like to technical. Yeah.
You just say you have to train twice a day, every morning, every everything.
Let's go, you feel tired. Let's go training. When I'm sick, like when I got,
I get a call, I just go running training and instead of people say, no,
I'm tired, I don't want to train,
I go training because I think the sport is the,
the best medication in the world. That's what I think. Even when you're sick,
even I'm going to sick and that's, that's worked because when you say training,
you're not kicking out sparring, not spying, just running in the bag,
hit the bag and not sparring because spelling is then I will contaminate my ass,
my guy terminate them. Yeah. That's funny. Yeah. So when you say mentor,
um, do you use a mental coach? Do you have no, no,
because I think some people need a mentor coach and some doesn't need for me,
like my story is, uh, I think I have my,
of course I need a mental coach, but I think I am my own mental coach. Uh,
my story for me is, is a big motivation for me. So tell everybody your story.
It's like, it's fucking long. But I can tell a short story like,
like when I think about everything, I, I,
I went through in my life, I'm talking like I'm, I'm, I'm 55, but
you've had a lot happen. Yeah, of course.
I was born in Cameroon and then, uh,
my mom moved to Paris when I was eight. And then one hour,
uh, later I, uh, we went, my sister and I,
we went to Paris to follow my mum. And uh, yeah, we was living in, uh,
in a small apartment, you know, very small apartment, one room, you know,
no water. We, we, we was, uh,
we went to the, how you said the,
the restaurant to ask water with big bottle of water empty.
We went to restaurant to ask what, uh, you know, it was, yeah,
my mom went through for so many things.
When I think about everything we went through in and when I'm in inside the
locker room, uh, I'm stressed, you know, uh, I'm nervous.
I just think about it and I say, Hey, listen, look where you are now.
You train for that, you train for this, you train for five.
Everybody waiting for you. Everybody is screaming, so don't get narrowed.
This is nothing, you know, so just go and, and uh, yeah.
Do what you like to do. Fight,
overcoming hardship a lot of times is the best teacher. Yeah, that's right.
So you know where you came from.
So you know the hardships and I know where I want to go, when I want,
where I want to land. So for me it's, um,
before I fight a Niko skin, I used to get nervous in the locker and I say,
hey,
you want to find any holes skin and are you nervous for this guy? Come on.
I know it is funny. It's like you get what you ask for. Yeah.
But while you're coming up, you're like, oh, I want to fuck that guy out.
Then all of a sudden you're like, oh shit. Yeah, no, he's fine. I was like,
man, this is the same with me. I talk a lot of shit on the Internet. Right?
And when I'm in the looking and I'm like, it's time.
Why don't I talk all that shit? Why did I say that?
I remember that the fight against yet I make a poster on Internet with his head.
Like I ripped that off and I was like gonna that's what's going to happen on the
during the fight. And he was like, no, I don't care about Internet.
I don't care about Instagram. I don't care about dark. I would talk in the ring.
I was like Paul
[inaudible] and during the fight it was in front of me and the referee was like,
check to Kansas for what if we'll if you like. He was like,
he wouldn't like to his corner like let's go. I want to fuck him up. And uh,
yeah, it was like, oh you talk, you talk shit, but now you have to back it up.
So I remember that fight.
It was very interesting cause I'm a big Nikki hold skin fan as well during the
collision. First one. Yeah, I remember that fight I was watching. I was like,
wow, like this guy,
he's got his number like you buy that.
By the time the fourth round came around I was like, you are,
you're ahead on points. And it looked like you had his style figured out.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was, this is, I think for me,
this is one of my best fights in the my best fight ever.
I was so small in this, in that fight. So yeah,
you're small in that fight. In what way? What do you say?
You said you were so small in that fight now. I said I was smart
because I didn't want to knock him out. I said I will knock him out.
But that was fake. Yeah. This was only a strategy, so I know I,
I will not, I will not knock him out because he's so strong. He's so smart.
And he's a counter the counter fighter. So yeah. I was very, very smart.
Make my ponds and then, yeah,
after tree fight against 'em tree fight after Nikki. Yeah.
People was calling me a runner because I was making a lot of points and,
and then now they're calling me in the number one powerful Paul in glory.
Isn't that crazy? Yeah. Nicki twice, twice. When did you find me again?
When was the second time I fought Nicki and then I fought Congo and then I
fought Nicki again and he beat him again. Yeah. Yeah. Point.
And after the fight, I remember I say you run too much.
I say respect my style. I respect your styles, but my style,
do you think you'd find them differently now? Mm,
yes. Yeah. Yeah. I think if I fight Nikki,
like tomorrow I will fail five different.
I will go for the knockout this time because I'm not the same fight as before.
So I think I was six, six. I will knock him out.
He's over in one I've seen now. Yeah.
Which is interesting cause they fight in a cage. Gambit little gloves too.
Yeah. No. Oh he's using boy time. Weta is sometime if I little glow,
they mix it up a lot of uh, a lot of different rules.
Yet when he knocked out cosmo Alexander dolls on [inaudible] was a crazy,
that was a crazy knock out. That shows you how good he is.
And then he see cosmo Alexander fuck up sage north cod.
And you realize how good cosmo was then. You see how bad Nicky beat up cosmo?
Yeah, Nikki's good. Yeah, it's very good. I like, you know, be before,
before I find Nikki, it was one of my, my, yeah,
my best fighter and I ever like,
because when I was watching him against Kevin Gadgets, the French fighter,
when I watch him against Joseph Walton. Amy, yeah. I was like, damn,
this is fucking fucking strong Raymond Daniels.
When he beat [inaudible] I was like, because for me just hunting,
it's not a, it's not an easy fight or any up and then he's very strong.
So they stopped him in the last round two with a right hook or maybe in left
hook [inaudible] who's a really good fighter. He got a little carried away,
was trying to trade with them and the end of the fight and then yeah,
Nicky caught him. I was like, I really, really liked this file.
And then when I, I,
when I received that email that I will face Nikos can, I was like
[inaudible] skin and you were only 24 at the time. Like Holy Shit, it's here.
Yeah. And I did. I didn't even have a strength and conditioning coach.
No. Only kickboxer, only Sameer boxing. And now as doing my,
my shit alone, running in the morning and just train by myself.
What kind of kick butt?
What kind of strength conditioning were you doing other than running pushups,
running some crossfit, but nothing like you're doing now. No, no, no.
I was doing things I was watching on youtube, you know,
so it was really crazy world champion watching stuff on youtube and learning.
It's great. What do we do with like John Jones? Uh, before when he started,
I heard about him,
he was saying that he saw the MMA watching a fights on a,
on youtube. Sure. Yeah. Cause you'd try moves out fights. Yeah.
So yeah, that's on some people just talented. Yeah.
Some people find a way. Now when you think about those fights,
like, and how important those fights were to you,
especially the Nikki Holtz can, when you look back,
it's gotta be kind of a crazy feeling that, that, that sort of,
that made your career that Nikki host can fight, particularly the first one.
Right. Because, you know,
my father was a little bit hilarious because the story of death fight,
uh,
I was the coal main event and I think that fight was,
was made for Niki owners can, you know,
because I had only three fights in Rory and the pull me a title shot as I was
edited a bit and entertaining and uh, I made pasta and things like that.
They say, okay, it's going to be a good, good show,
but that's going to be a fight for Nicki. You know, for sure.
I think they say to themselves, nick,
you're going to win the fight because it's undefeated. You know,
nobody could beat him. You're gonna win the fight. And uh, yeah.
Is the fight just before by the Varian Rico fights?
So a lot of eyes was, uh, on,
so I just created the surprise and the, yeah, I just surprised everybody.
And uh, that's why I have a lot of friends in Morocco because the,
there was waiting for better every fight and they sh they saw me.
So it was like I received a lot of beside from Morocco, like, oh my brother,
I really like your style. You funny and uh, yeah. And Moroccans love fights.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. It was wild people. I liked American, uh,
American fans and Moroccan people because I yeah.
Went to Purcell during two years in presales.
A lot of American people in Holland also. I love American people.
Do you think you'll be fighting on the next Rico bought or horrified?
It seems like you think so? Yeah. It seems like when is that?
Because before that there is a December, December before December.
There was two events in the, in the,
in October. And uh, they are, they're almost booked.
So I think for me it's going to be December.
It's going to be a good thing cause I like better area. Yes. And uh, yeah,
to fight in the same court. This is my third time.
I will fight in the same color. I same as bar.
I'm very interested to see how he fights Rico in the second fight me to very,
very interesting because good though. Very good.
So it's not crazy cardio for Chris [inaudible] and he moves like a,
like a welterweight. Yes. When he fights, if I had like a worker,
it's not like a regular weight one. He beat everybody in every division.
He beats everybody. Yeah. He told me that when he was training,
when he was coming up, he was training with the light guys. Yeah. So he's like,
you had to move. Yeah. He's like,
so he developed that cardio and that ability from training with guys like 180
pounds. Yeah. Yeah. That's why for me and the fight he,
he the way photo getting to Jamal, Ben said they go, yeah.
It was almost almost done about the festival the second, I don't remember.
It was almost done. And then they will knock him out back.
And the last or the fourth month, the forefront, it was crazy. I was like, man,
this dude, this is a good champ. It was a rich him, but so smart.
It's very smart. But you know, I like, I really,
I think people like butter already because,
because of everything he story because of the man, the bad boy. Yeah.
And then I just [inaudible] yeah, he's very strong and he's,
it's really cool to watch. And uh, and when, when Buzzer Com,
when the, when the,
the speaker called [inaudible] and he comes in to him,
the mood is just, you know, everybody is,
you can see the flash or ev of many phones in the outage and no, it's crazy.
It's very crazy feeling when, when Butler very fight, he's the most famous cat.
He's the most famous cause bucks and he's a legend and he's not just a legend
because of his fighting, which has been, he's been an incredible fighter,
but also just cause he's so crazy. Yeah. So much wild shit.
He's always getting in trouble. Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
That's people love by the right because of the fighter,
but also because of the bad boy. Yeah.
It's funny fighters that get in trouble in Conor McGregor has been in a bunch of
trouble lately. Yeah. You know,
some people are upset at them and some people are not and it's just,
it's not good. You know, everything is not good. But he's a wild man. Wild Man.
Do Wild Shit. Yeah. Not good to smack that guy at the bar though.
I watched that again. I thought it was like a touch last time I talked about it.
I thought he just sorta touched him in the head with his hand.
I saw the video with a slab. It looks like almost like a punch. Yeah,
almost like a buzz. Yeah, he hit him. I misspoke. I thought he just,
I basically thought he just touched him in the face because I watched it on my
phone and it just wasn't that clear. No going gonna Watch on a computer.
I was like, Damn. What does, what does it do you do that? I don't know.
Maybe the guy said something really bad to him, but either one is a,
is another guy, you know, you just, and you're a big star, so
a guy at a bar doesn't want your whiskey with your as fuck.
But he's all that the wild shit.
Like grabbing that guy's phone and stomping on it. I saw that.
This just a little too crazy. Just a little too crazy.
Sometime I didn't understand. Maybe it was drunk. I don't know.
Probably maybe something else. Yeah.
All I can say nothing about it, but um, yeah,
maybe it was drank. That's what I thought. At first I was like, he was drunk so,
but maybe in your team mate control you, you know Yo guy May. Got You.
Yeah. Bikes. If you offer a man at a bar,
a drink and he doesn't want it and you punch him in the head,
definitely fuck it up. He's definitely making some mistakes,
but I love watching him. Fight is a while, dude.
It's amazing how many fans he has. Two,
I've never seen anything like it or one early on,
early on in his career before he was a champion.
I remember after the fight when you, when you slept guys,
you'll name keep you keep building up,
but the problem with him is going to be guys like could be and he wants a
rematch with could be. I don't think so. I don't think could be.
He was kind of fired up. It can be fucked him up. Why would he fight him again?
That's right. I think money. Fight. Yeah.
I think the money fight fan him is Nate nasal fighting. Again,
that's a big fight. But Nate,
they're talking about Nate fighting Mossville doll, you know, he fights.
So Jorge Mazda doll, I think that fight is a, that's a huge fight as well.
And you know, Connor may or may not ever fight again. Like who knows?
He says he's going to, but I, he does. Yeah. Maybe.
Maybe boy just, yeah, maybe [inaudible] has got a fight. Could be, you know,
I mean that's next month. That's, that's the big fight. Right.
And Khabib is the big, I mean Khabib is the only one undefeated in division.
His wrestling is fucking terrifying. It gets people on the ground,
just shit out of them. I see. More like Aka, it was just crazy.
[inaudible] yeah, he's thought it. It's studying a combustible when he was,
when he was kid. You ever see how they play basketball?
So we'll Harris my friend will Harris productions.
He's been in here before as well.
He filmed these guys playing basketball over there and you watch those watching
that book guests and that after that video I just went to the youtube to watch
the video you was talking about and the, yeah, the bus could book crazy.
It's crazy. The Western bus get play, wrestle basketball,
what the fuck are you doing?
And then get the guy in our rear naked choke and the guy
who keeps going, you can't even tap like the whole thing. So like there,
there are hard people over there and man, they are hard people.
I watched the buzzer they was looking about,
he went there to film the Bib and yes he wouldn't yet.
What's will's very talented will Harris.
He does a great job of capturing these guys' stories and put it in.
He's a nice guys who people like him. So they're,
they're loose and relaxed around and he's very talented as a filmmaker.
So when he puts these, these pieces together, they're very impactful.
And that fame is on the youtube. Yes, yes. All that stuff is on youtube.
What is this Conor McGregor to face? Floyd Mayweather in Japan. What
it is today. That, so this is, I just looked up his name,
that's why I brought it up.
There's a game show they supposedly have signed to be on where they're going to
compete against each other and this says he signed or he's going to sign for
report at $10 million to do it.
Do a game show on contacts so it won't bring show
break contract or anything. So he's gonna get that much money for that.
Like 10 million bucks for a game. So,
well they paid Floyd $9 million to fight that, uh, t jumping up.
He's supposed to be part of that too. Yeah. Tension. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not as who cow, who's a bad motherfucker, but he's tiny,
so small and a lot of people thought that that fight was fixed with him and
Floyd. I was like, no, like even good fun. Good.
Like fight commentators thought that was fake. I was like,
watch it and watch it again. Doll first road, Dude.
Wait on your 20 pounds. He fights 126 pounds.
Floyd beat the fuck out of him. He's so much bigger. Flay was so loose,
you just walked in. Just clubbed him in the head. This is crazy.
When you fight frilly Marita, you missed train like a, like you ever did that?
Like they didn't even give him enough chance.
Like the inflow was couple of months. Yes. Fetty yeah.
Well he didn't have to get in shape for that guy. Look fairly this way.
Bigger than him. Way Bigger. I mean Floyd is not a big man.
It's way bigger than tension. Tension's tiny.
He's a tiny little as but against those other 120 pound guys,
he fucks those guys up. He's really very good. Very even kick boxing is very,
very, very, very interesting to win the fight. He does like wild shit,
like weird spinning kicks and stuff like his fight of very good like my second
Dorio so I'm sure one of my favorite fighter in Japan. Independence. Yes.
And then tweens Bruzzo so a Europe up, we rub it and the other guy in the norm,
it's damaging to tensions legacy because everybody thought he was a joke after
Floyd. Even if he left it,
Floyd let him kick it. Would it be a different fight? That's what I was hoping.
I was hoping when they were there talking about a fight, I was like,
is this going to be a, a kickboxing fight?
Like maybe Floyd be so crazy that he said, go ahead and kick.
Let's see what's up. Fuck his legs off course.
There's only been a few, a world champion boxers. Uh, Vince Phillips,
remember when he fought? He fought in Japan. He fought, uh,
Masato Masako my southern fucked his legs off whack.
This guy was a book. So yes. World champion. Cool. Vince Phillips. Yeah. See,
pull that up. Vince Phillips versus Masato and Vince was like,
at the end of his career, he's like 40 is Clinogen Vince fitted. Ah,
I think he's American. I, he's American. Um, and um,
Masako just fucked his legs up. Dan kicked his legs out from under him. Friends,
both of them remember friends. Both that he fought Tyson.
There is Vince Phillips and you know, Vince was just,
it was, it was a fight was just a terrible idea.
And he's fighting barefoot and I mean, he really should've fought with shoes on.
Just said, I'm not going to kick cause he wasn't gonna kick anyway,
but Masato just fucked those legs up.
You didn't train like a kickboxer Huh? Just went to the phone, man.
I know because look, he's getting lit up. Shannon Briggs did too.
Shannon Shannon the cannon, he went over there and he f Oh,
see he's already done his Galen, um, I think it was k one. Yes.
They,
I mean they basically just set it up so making his leg Masato just foxes legs
up, kicked into his arms and everything. I mean,
Masako barely tried to box with them and look and he's already done.
He can't even punch anymore. His arms are fucked up.
And then Masato is trying to Niamh. I mean, he's fucking those legs up, man.
It's a like a master class in how to fuck up a a world class boxer with kicks.
See, look, Masako is dirty. He's getting them to bite those faints. Like,
look at that leg kick right there. Ooh. You know, he's done.
His leg is toast right now. He could barely walk.
Like we were always trying to walk around and he's just hanging in there,
hanging in there. I can't, yeah, just there it is. There it is.
There it is. Yeah. He's fucked. Like he's an agony. You can boom.
Yeah, a book again, the kickbox and know you can't, it's amazing.
And people just don't know. They really don't know.
They don't know what it feels like to be like kicked,
especially by a guy like you.
Even the kickboxer even me when I get a low kick,
you crazy. Even the first round in the,
in the ring because you're in the locker room, you're just running up, you know,
and yeah. But when you inside ring punches and kick is,
you feel me? I don't know. Maybe twice, 10 times more than the,
in the gym. It's not the same like a spring and a fight his,
it's not really the same. No cause of, yeah, the pressure, the light, the,
the, the, yeah. Everything is different. Charming. You know, everything.
Even the, the, the smell of, of your, your opening and buddy.
Some people don't watch just so they stink when they fight. They like to do it.
Matt Lindland apparently was famous for that and he used to wrestle that way.
He used to not not wash himself and then like we'd guys would fight on.
They'd be like, what the fuck? One of them, one of my left upland,
he was thinking us, fuck. I can say he can't say his name.
He wasn't Gloria. I was like damn I the first one that he clinched me.
I was like [inaudible] crazy.
You think they do that on purpose? No, I don't think so. Well it's a good move.
I don't think it fuck with your head a little bit.
I was like [inaudible] think
I can be a good move to smell really bad. Yeah.
Maybe guys wouldn't want to have anything to do with you cause I don't think
they test for that. Sometimes people put ty or on the gloves.
Oh I had this one time when I fought in the friends and the final of the
tournament I was after the first one I was, my skin was burning.
I was like Blah. Seems like somebody put me, you know,
tight all on the face and get in your eyes. Yeah.
And after the fight, my coach told me Creamy, you know
this, that team used to do that.
They put on their gloves for the first round and then they just punched you on
the, on the face, on your eyes. They just clean shoe. And uh,
after the first one you fucked up. Like, that's terrible. It's crazy.
I don't know how people can do that, if you will. Even if she been in the fight,
they don't test for that.
They don't check to make sure sometimes the referee smell the gloss, you know,
the whole before. It's a small organization.
It's not like glory you can do in glory, you know? Did you ever find more ties?
Well, I fought two times. Yeah.
And with errors two times two k o did you fight the same way?
Your same style with a lot of movement and a lot of movement. Yes. But was, uh,
was, yeah. [inaudible] first at the first round. Yeah.
As I said before, I used to kill people first one I didn't care about.
I just go boom, boom, boom, kill, kill, kill before Gloria.
Because now grow is high level that fighters, it's not easy to knock them out.
Who Do you, uh,
who do you think like the best fighters in glory outside of here?
Outside of me. You enjoy watching? If Nicaea was still there,
I would say Nikki, but as nick is not anymore, uh,
which fight I like to Boyd is gone.
Also Rubin when Huisman is really like he's going to fight MMA. Yeah.
His guy. He's training in Florida with Henry Hoofed. Oh yeah, yeah. In 14.
And that's when he told me. Yeah. But now as the rubbing his gun,
a guy I like to watch fight. Um, yeah.
Instead of bothering me but already don't fight the often.
Yeah. I don't know. There are many fighter I likes.
So, um,
so we can look forward to fighting against some time around December hopefully.
Yeah. And then yeah, when you do decide to come to the UFC,
please come back and we'll talk about it and we'll, we'll make an announcement.
We'll make a big deal out of it. What do you mean? I want,
when you do fight in the UFC, you leave glory. You want [inaudible].
Yeah, of course. Of course.
That's a big deal to have a guy like you world champion kickboxer make it,
make it to the UFC. That'd be fantastic. That's one of my, yeah, my big ring.
If, if I had Dana white in front of me right now, I could hook that up.
I would say, Hey Dan, I was up. So you trust the chimp now, right?
You Trust Camaro's Mana, you trust your fighter, right?
I'm the best. I'm the best in kickboxing.
I'm the best in combat sport and I can beat your champ and I can became,
become your next champ. I'm the future. You know, I'm 26.
All those people in, in welterweight division, um,
hold off to watch.
So yeah, I'm the future and I,
I really think I gonna I gonna beat anybody in the division.
Well, there's guys that you're gonna have to fight first.
I'm just going to be honest with you. They're not gonna give you a title shot.
They don't want to see you fight against a good fighter.
But they could give you a fight against a top 10 contender. Yeah.
Because like guys like Kamara Uzman and they earn their way to be a champion.
Of course, you can't just jump right in there. I agree. And, but that's,
that's why he's my dream. But a guy like Anthony Pettis, yeah.
Who's still in elite fighter but who just lost Nate Diaz. That is possible.
That is possible. Yeah. If you came in with a lot of hype and, and I noticed,
you know,
and obviously Gloria's is on UFC fight pass and they have an agreement with
Gloria. Cool. So they could use your highlight reel. Oh yeah, yeah, of course.
And we could sell it even Greek and talk with UFC and we can make something.
And I think, yeah, I don't think I will do it. So yeah. But this is good.
And then specialty is a Stryker. Yes. That's what makes it interesting. Yeah.
Pedes would try to stand with you maybe with first. Yeah. Uh, yeah.
As a confidence first I was thinking about [inaudible] because I really like the
way you fight is so crazy. Yes. Yeah. Yes. And I think yeah.
And because also nobody could knock him out.
Maybe I'm wrong. Well, Josh Thompson knocked him out. Yeah. In the UFT,
tried him on the head kick. I thought nobody couldn't knock him also.
That's what I wanted to be the first. No,
Josh Thompson who is probably one of the most underrated fighters ever who was
one of the very best in the world.
But then he left the UFC when the UFC dropped the 155 pound division many,
many years back. And he went over to strike force and became one of the best,
you said it's absolutely one of the most unheralded uh,
professional fighters over there. He's an elite elite fighter,
but he knocked out Nate d so they had to talk to him. Yeah, he's the only guy.
Well, he stopped him.
He dropped him with the head kick and then finished him off to ivy.
I be the second one. Well, maybe you'd be the first guy to submit him. Yeah,
maybe. [inaudible] good luck with that.
But uh, listen man, I'm a fan is a honor. Have you in here.
I really appreciate your time. And, uh,
we're gonna take some pictures of you working out here. Cool. Great. Yeah.
Alright. Says you're doing bay ladies and gentlemen. Thank you, brother.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
[inaudible].